This is the US Coast Guard
intercepting a shipment of cocaine.
Here's the same crew intercepting
another one... and another one.
This was all in the summer of 2018. They seized more
than 9,000 kilos of cocaine that
was headed to the US.
That may sound like a lot but it's just the tip of the iceberg.
In 2017 the Coast Guard
intercepted almost 227,000 kilos of cocaine, here.
Along the eastern Pacific.
That's because the US is the largest cocaine
consumer in the world. And to get to the
US, most of that cocaine has to travel
this way, through Central America and
Mexico.
With that comes violence and today Guatemala and Honduras are some of
the most violent places in the world.
It's a big reason why so many people are
traveling north to seek asylum at the
US-Mexico border.
But the story of Central America's crisis isn't just
about America's demand for drugs.
Another big part of it...is America's war on drugs.
Cocaine is produced in South America
along the Andes mountain range that
stretches from Bolivia to Colombia.
Starting in the mid 1970s most of the
world's cocaine came from here;
distributed by groups like the Medellin
Cartel led by Pablo Escobar.
But they needed to get their product, here, to the US.
Where by the late 80s Americans were
spending tens of billions of dollars on
cocaine annually.
And they did it this way:
Cartels sent boats and planes loaded
with cocaine through the Caribbean to
South Florida. For example Escobar's
cartel primarily flew cocaine from
Medellin to the Bahamas and then over to
Miami.
"Miami is one of the principal branch offices for what can be called
cocaine Inc. It's got to be four or five
times as much cocaine as we've ever seen
before... The drug has killed at least 34 people
just in South Florida so far this year."
So the US cracked down on the Caribbean route.
"To stop those drugs on the way to America I propose that we
Spend more than a billion and a half dollars on interdiction.
They started
catching shipments along the coast line.
Like this speedboat called a go-fast
boat that was intercepted by the Coast
Guard. And they worked with the Colombian
government to destroy coca and fight the
cartels in Colombia.
The Caribbean route was dismantled but
the cocaine industry kept going.
Cartels just needed a new route to the
US, and they found it in Mexico.
Mexican cartels already had ways to get drugs over their border and into the u.s.
So, Colombian cartels shipped their cocaine to Mexico but their boats and planes had
to stop somewhere along the way to avoid detection and to refuel. And the ideal
place to stop was Central America,
especially Honduras and Guatemala.
Not only were these countries directly south of Mexico,  but they had just been through
decades of civil wars and foreign
interventions. Their governments were
weak and easily bought off and criminal
organizations had power. It was an easy
place for the cartels to turn to.
Back in Mexico, the new cocaine routes turned lucrative, fast.
The Mexican cartels got bigger and
more powerful and started controlling
more territory. And the government
responded... "It's a war! 10,000 federal
troops and police to Juarez.
Mexico cracked down with the help of the US.
"He will not allow his country to be taken
over by narco traffickers" This crackdown
was largely a failure.
It caused chaos and violence spiked. But it did make it more difficult to send cocaine directly
to Mexico. So cartels started shipping
cocaine to Central America, to landing
points along the coasts, and would move
it into Mexico overland.
Central America wasn't just a stop along
the way anymore.
Suddenly it found itself at the center
of cocaine trafficking.
And all the things that made Central American countries ideal as refueling stops made
them vulnerable to the violence that
comes with drug routes.
Criminal organizations, already powerful in their countries, started forming alliances with
Mexican cartels. In Guatemala, this group
aligned with the Zetas while these went
with the rival Sinaloa cartel.
Violence surged here: along the northern
Honduran coast where cocaine shipments arrived and at the border where the
cocaine is transported north by land.
With violence on the rise
it was now Central America's turn to
crackdown throughout the region...
Governments embraced harsh policies to
combat not just drug traffickers but all
organized crime. A policy, backed again,
by the US: "To find ways in which we can
come up with more aggressive action
plans to improve security. We have a
shared responsibility when it comes to
dealing with drug trafficking."
Newly militarized police forces arrested
thousands, prisons filled up, but the
violence didn't stop. And that's where we
are today. Honduras and Guatemala have
violent death rates on par with active
war zones.
And thousands of migrants are taking dangerous routes through Mexico
to the US to escape the instability and
violence. For decades the US has tried to
stop drugs from coming in but it's only
really succeeded in changing how those
drugs come in. And Central America might
be the place that's feeling those
changes the hardest.
Hey if you've made it this far in the video you're probably the kind of curious person that
appreciates learning. Brilliant is a
problem-solving website that teaches you
to think like a scientist and be a
better problem solver. They have courses
on everything from calculus to astronomy
to logic and daily problems in math,
science, engineering, and computer science.
To learn more about Brilliant, go to
Brilliant.org/vox and sign up for
free. The first 200 people will get 20%
off their annual premium subscription.
Brilliant doesn't influence our editorial
at all but it makes videos like this one
possible, so go check them out!